so you remember I said that I heard our
heading wasn't finished and I was going
to fill in this pot right we've looked
at sequences we're going to in a series
these progressions there are two
families of them that are particularly
useful to us because they're accessible
the the maths of them is not hard to
understand but also they lead to very
important places in later topics okay so
the other kind of progression that were
interested in this morning is called a
geometric progression arithmetic
progressions geometric progressions
hence we call them GPS not to be
confused with general practitioners
right nothing to do with them I would
like to have a think and I'll give you
an answer at the end and you can remind
me if I forget you um why exactly these
are called
geometric progressions whereas these are
called add like what makes these things
do you mention because I don't think
it's obvious but if you ever think about
it like if the questions on your mind
you might wake it up in IV so again I'm
going to go through pattern formula
bukhari and how to test for whether
something is this kind of progression or
not okay now you met these yesterday we
have this common difference you add
something you add something that you add
something that's the hallmark of an AP
okay go home I give you GP it's very
similar you still start with the first
term that we still call a but instead of
adding the same thing repeatedly
multiply and the multiplier and the you
multiply each is the same number time
now because here we're adding we called
it a difference when you multiply by
something over and over again we tend to
call that a ratio right so instead of ad
I'm going to call this next term a times
R when I multiply again to get to the
next term I multiplied by R again so
it's going to be a square
yeah it's kind of funny because because
my birthday is international speak like
a pirate day so it's kind of like you
know anyway I've got three times that's
pretty bad once we have their patent if
their foot doesn't take much to work out
what the formula for each in turn each
in turn is going to be and there's a
striking similarity to our formula for
the APS right I'm always going to start
with a right I'm gonna have that common
ratio in there how many common ratios
does the intern get x and then the
answer is just like with the common
differences it's going to be n minus 1
you see that right the first term
doesn't have any vakama ratio in it the
second term has one of them both third
term has two mm etcetera okay a R to the
N minus 1 in exactly the same way from
here I could go to a recursive
definition right so I don't need to
write recursion again I can simply say
we log in the first term as egg once you
know what the first term is you can get
any subsequent term the end turn by
saying what you'd be the previous term
times but multiplying right so I'm just
going to write that are out the front
okay to get to the next term you take
the previous term you multiply by
whatever the ratio goes okay now
remember the reason why is this it's not
because it's actually much used in
solving questions but it's useful to
generate this guy the tests right so how
do I test whether a sequence or a series
is a GP or not I'm going to take the
same kind of comparison right I want to
do something with a pair of consecutive
terms right what am I gonna do I'm not
going to subtract I'm going to
by right so I'm going to take one term
divide it by the previous one right
every single one of those should be
equal to the common ratio for every term
that you give me right all values of n
minutes apply now just like before
you're pretty much going to get three
times right
so therefore in reality what you're
checking is the first pair on the second
pair you want to check that those ratios
line up in other words that turn to
divide by turn one is the same as turn
3/2 okay so this is what it is generally
speaking but this is pretty much what
you'll do each time okay now let's start
again I'm gonna ask a very similar set
of questions with GPS that we did with a
page right in fact I'm gonna ask for
Miss on identical question which is
let's find some terms that's a nice easy
way to start that's a super way to use
this formula okay so the first four
terms when they're just like I needed
two things to define maybe I need two
things to define a GP so it's not a
common difference is it first term and
our treasure so let's just say a nice
easy number like soup because as you'll
see geometric pressures they take it
across every class oh yeah sure thank
you it was funny he wasn't it
sorry yes exponential
well that's exactly how fast now when we
write out this series okay
I'm obviously you get the first terms of
three which is nice to get to the next
term I'm going to double which of course
just gives me six and then and then
twelve it's ready for restoring my faith
in humanity guys thank you okay
so there are my first four terms
so get straight to the 11 turn again
just like before I'll let them write
down to get it into my head at this
early stage I'm gonna write down my
formula right erase them a to the N
minus 1 and I know what a and r are okay
so I'm going to like to see it right
three times which is which is 1024 it's
worth mentioning because of the nature
of a geometric series
this is seconds my pen that to the power
whatever right order whatever to the
power whatever sometimes it can be just
astronomically large okay so depending
on the question you know sometimes just
leave it in this bowl just leave it even
export because this is me some dumb huge
dollar what's the point
okay I've worked out what it is my
calculator does the rest
okay in this case it's relatively small
in the scheme of things I happen to know
for the two to power of 2024 because by
an AMA geek it's funny what you guys
bye-bye 3072 you happy with that it's
not okay